hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser
wunderbaren neuen Podcast Folge vom
alltagspodcast der heißt nicht so ich
glaube mittlerweile könnte ich den
grau-haarabdeckung nennen weil meine
grauen Haare sind schon wieder so lang
geworden und ich möchte diese Zeit hier
mal ganz gerne nutzen in der ich meine
Haare färbt um einfach mit euch zu
quatschen ich dachte ist das nicht ein
wunderbares ist nicht eine wunderbare
Kombination von zwei Dingen die ich sehr
gerne tue mit euch reden und meine Haare
färben eine Sache davon mache ich nicht
so gerne ihr könnt jetzt raten welches
ist ich habe gerade tatsächlich auch
selber ein Podcast gehört von Rin und
Tim Gabel mega gut ich bin richtig also
nicht verliebt in rin aber dass der mir
mal so gute Lebensweisheiten geben kann
und das meine ich nicht mal übertrieben
schaut euch den auf jeden Fall mal an
der dauert drei Stunden ich habe jetzt
188 davon gehört
wo ich mich jetzt heute hier so
vorbereitet habe und blablabla ich weiß
noch nicht was die nächsten eineinhalb
Stunden beinhalten aber es ist auf jeden
Fall sehr hörenswert wenn ihr Zeit habt
nach diesem Podcast bitte also wenn ihr
selber irgendwas zu tun habt eure Haare
färben müsst so wie ich
aufräumen müsst die Wäsche machen müsst
was auch immer dann hört euch das gerne
nebenbei an ihr müsst auch nicht ganze
Zeit mein Gesicht anschauen ganz ehrlich
ich weiß ich sehe heute fantastisch aus
und ich frage mich auch warum meine
Haare gerade heute irgendwie gut liegen
obwohl sie so ein bisschen trocken sind
ich möchte auch unbedingt mal so
Apfelessig da rein machen Berliner
Wasser ist ja so kaltig da sehen Haare
einfach aus ja wie sie aussehen ne
trocken und irgendwie so beschichtet
ja und heute
möchte ich über das Thema Milch sprechen
Müll ist etwas was vielleicht erstmal
langweilig klingt aber haltet ein hört
mir erstmal zu ich finde das Thema
nämlich sehr wichtig und viel zu wenig
besprochen ich hatte schon meine
Kooperation mit Mülltrennung wirkt und
ich glaube das hat bei mir noch mal so
ein extra Ding ausgelöst vor allem weil
als ich die Kooperation hatte das war so
als Mr Videos und ich glaube auch ein
Instagram Post ja ähm da habe ich halt
mich mehr mit dem Thema beschäftigt wie
Müll getrennt wird aber auch schon
vorher also es war vorher schon
Leidenschaft von mir wenn man das bei
mir so sagen kann ist jetzt nicht mein
Hobby aber es ist schon es ist mir
wichtig einfach es ist ein Thema das
finde ich sehr wichtig und jeder hat ja
irgendwo sein Steckenpferd ne der eine
engagiert sich für Tierschutz der andere
für alte Menschen
oder für alles ist auch super wenn man
die Zeit und die Leidenschaft hat
fantastisch dann bist du ein super
toller Mensch bei mir ist es halt Müll
das heißt jetzt nicht dass man alte
Menschen nicht wichtig sind aber ich
glaube ihr wisst was ich meine ja und
heute möchte ich über das Thema Müll
sprechen dabei färbe ich mir die Haare
und da ist fängt ja auch schon an ne das
hier zu entsorgen da ist jetzt so Reste
drin so komische Haarfarbe Rest wenn ich
damit fertig bin und das ist so eine
Verpackung die besteht aus Pappe aber
die ist ja so beschichtet da müsste ich
eigentlich noch mal nachfragen und dann
ist auch das Problem hat sich diese
Kooperation gemacht hat habe ich viele
Nachrichten bekommen dass es eine arte
DoKu gibt die Recycling Lüge
und das war halt
auch schwierig weil in dieser arte Doku
wird quasi so ein bisschen gezeigt dass
viele Sachen die man vielleicht richtig
trennt nicht richtig recycelt werden und
da ist es natürlich als allererstes
wichtig dass man Müll überhaupt
vermeidet und da kommen wir zu unserem
Kooperationspartner heute ich bin
wirklich sehr happy über diesen
Kooperationspartner und zwar oh ja oh ja
ist eine periodenunterwäsche und ihr
wisst ich benutze schon sehr lange
Perioden Unterwäsche und da zeige ich
euch mal wie wunderhübsch sie ist sie
ist ein bisschen groß aber das liegt
daran dass ich einen großen Hintern habe
ne aber ich bin richtig happy mit dieser
Periode Unterwäsche weil die Qualität
wirklich toll ist die sitzt mega gut und
sie vermeidet einfach das Benutzen von
anderen Sachen wie Tampons was ich
eigentlich hauptsächlich früher immer
gemacht habe Tampons getragen so
vielleicht auch meine Binde aber Tampons
ja wirklich einfach praktischer obwohl
sie wirklich sehr unpraktisch sind
ständig diese Tampons
nahrungswechsel wenn ich zum Beispiel
mal die Unterwäsche nicht benutze es ist
so nervig und nicht nur nervig es
produziert halt auch extrem viel Müll
und das ist bei periodenunterwäsche halt
einfach nicht der Fall du trägst sie du
wäscht sie und sie sieht sogar super
toll aus ich habe hier noch eine mit
also ich will nicht sagen dass sie so
ein bisschen Sex ist da kannst du da
hast du deine Periode fühlt sich
vielleicht nicht so ja so ne an dem Tag
und dann und ich habe noch eine dritte
und dann habe ich mich gefragt wo die
ist habe die gerade wirklich gesucht und
dachte mir so ne die hat so ein
elastisches Band ja die trage ich gerade
vielleicht habe ich auch deswegen so ein
strahlenden Tag heute weil ich mitten in
meiner Periode bin bei nicht ganz so
starken Tagen ziehe ich morgens eine an
und dann abends wenn ich duschen war
oder so dann wechsel ich sie für die
Nacht und für die Nacht finde ich
wirklich so angenehm ich brauche halt
nichts anderes als diese Unterhose man
schläft irgendwie so gut und es läuft
nichts aus man ist einfach
wohlig eingepackt und ich bin super
happy also probiert es gerne aus mit dem
Code malwanne bekommt ihr zehn Prozent
ab 25 Euro im Warenkorb ihr könnt sogar
noch doppelt sparen wenn ihr drei US
kauft dann bekommt ihr free Shipping und
der Link dazu ist noch meine Infobox ich
habe hier sogar noch mal eine Verpackung
und jetzt geht's weiter mit dem Video
Podcast heute habe ich sogar Handschuhe
dabei letztes Mal habe ich keine
Handschuhe getragen es ist mir dann erst
später aufgefallen und dann hatte ich so
ein bisschen Flecken auf den Händen aber
heute no way zurück zum Thema warum Müll
ich habe ja jetzt die letzten Wochen
schon mal meine ersten Schubladen
ausgemistet ne und habe den Flohmarkt
gemacht falls ihr das Video verpasst
habt schaut euch gerne vorbei Video an
ähm es hat sehr Spaß gemacht also
Flohmarkt ist wirklich das kann ich
empfehlen da bin ich Fan jetzt von wir
haben ein bisschen Sekt getrunken das
war vielleicht nicht so eine ganz gute
Idee weil dann habe ich echt schlechte
Preise gemacht aber
scheiß drauf wir hatten eine gute Zeit
also wenn ihr Freunde habt mit denen ihr
das machen könnt macht mit euren
Freunden anstatt alleine aber wie alles
im Leben oder ja und dabei ist mir
einfach aufgefallen dass man ja wirklich
viel Zeug ansammelt auch so über die
Jahre und das ist ja eigentlich nicht
Müll also es ist ja alles Zeug und und
man sieht vielleicht dann selber als
Müll wenn man damit nichts mehr anfangen
kann aber ich kann das z.B nicht
wegschmeißen weil es also wenn mir fällt
auch einfach schwer Dinge wegzuschmeißen
so wirklich so kleiner bastel Plastik
Scheiße irgendwie und das alles so auf
dem Haufen zu sehen
manche Sachen haben noch Anhänger
gefunden bei den wirklich kleinsten
Teilchen wollte es auch keiner mehr
haben aber wirsli wo ich jetzt halt
vielleicht das noch mal unten bei meinen
Nachbarn als verschenken mache aber ich
denke auch nicht dass die das dann haben
wollen und ich habe das Gefühl wir so
als Gesellschaft wir versinken so im
Müll im Zeug vor allem und es ist halt
sehr rich dass ich das sage weil ich
natürlich auch viele Sachen teste und so
aber ich sehe das noch mal abgesetzt als
für euer Entertainment oder für unser
aller Entertainment probiere ich Sachen
aus zum Beispiel Amazon Gadgets für den
Strand oder so und wenn er eine Sache
z.B dazwischen ist die ja gut findet
dann holt ihr euch vielleicht diese eine
Sache die ich euch dann gezeigt habe
aber keiner holt sich ja zehn Gadgets so
ich bin in einer anderen Position dass
bei mir halt so viel Zeug dann auch noch
von Video drehst da ist das muss ich
einfach
unterscheiden und ich hatte lange Zeit
Schwierigkeit arbeiten das zu
unterscheiden gerade auch wenn es um
backen und sowas geht und und Geräte die
man für die Küche dann zu Hause hat und
ich habe ja diverse Waffeleisen ich habe
drei Waffeleisen und das ist ja
eigentlich viel zu viel ich darf aber
ich musste differenzieren dass das dass
ich drei Waffeleisen habe weil das zu
meinem Job gehört ich meine bei
irgendeiner Fernsehproduktion haben
keine Ahnung was da alles an Bühne oder
an an Geräten gekauft gebaut und sonst
was gemacht wird
da ist also das gehört halt dazu und ich
finde es auch
nicht so schlimm wenn das halt wenn man
seinen eigenen privaten Konsum bewusst
erlebt so das ist so schon mal dieser
eine Müll dieser Haushalts oder dieser
gegenstandsmüll ich komme da auch immer
nur so drauf weil wenn ich auf dem
Wertstoffhof bin nein immer so was haben
wir denn alles also gerade der Sperrmüll
wo dann die Leute da ihre Sofas und so
reinschmeißen das blutet mir manchmal
echt das Herz weil dann sich da
irgendwie so ein Stuhl oder so und so
von guck dir das nicht mehr so das ist
doch jetzt wirklich kein Müll also das
ist doch eigentlich noch gut oder
vielleicht ist da dieses eine Bein
locker aber das kann man doch noch
festschrauben und das fällt mir schon
extrem schwer deswegen habe ich auch so
über so viele Jahre halt auch so viel
Zeug angesammelt weil ich kann Sachen
nicht einfach in den Hausmüll schmeißen
so ich hatte so eine kleine
Porzellanfigur wo ich dann beim
Ausmisten und auch gesagt habe okay aber
die ist kaputt und da die kann man nicht
mehr reparieren das war ja aus Porzellan
aus irgendein nanuna Material ne
okay das das muss jetzt unbedingt und
das tut mir so weh ich weiß nicht ob das
so vom Kindheit ich will jetzt nicht
Trauma sagen aber von diesem Kindheit
nichts haben ne alles alles sparen alles
irgendwie
ja also so von diesem von dieser
Gewissheit dass dass man nicht alles so
hat aber der Müll der ja wirklich das
Problem ist und Candy hat er ja auch
schon mal ein Video darüber gemacht dass
wir den Müll hinterher fahren also
einerseits dass wir zu viel Müll
produzieren das ist ja also absolut klar
ich weiß aber auch nicht also wie man da
wirklich eine Besserung hinkriegen kann
denn es ist in manchen bubbles und
gerade auf Social Media und im Internet
ist es natürlich toll wie bewusst
minimalistisch und achtsam die Leute mit
solchen Themen umgehen und und Müll
vermeiden und gucken
alles ja irgendwie irgendwie ethisch
moralisch vertretbar ist aber das ist ja
auch für viele andere Menschen nicht die
Realität die in einer anderen
finanziellen Situation sind die ja wenn
man es auch so sagt sich freuen wenn sie
irgendwie günstig Klamotten auf schihen
kaufen ist der größte Rotz aber es
funktioniert halt weil da so viele Leute
in so finanziellen Situation sind dass
sie in dieser schnellen Welt in der
Trends sich ständig wechseln irgendwie
mithalten wollen und dann fühlen sie
sich gezwungen da einzukaufen und ich
habe absolut keine Ahnung wie man das
retten soll wie man das stoppen kann ich
denke mal durch gute Vorbilder also wenn
Influenza und Personen der öffentlichen
Lebens das mehr vertreten das
Nachhaltigkeit Müllvermeidung cool ist
dann würden wir wahrscheinlich schon mal
einen großen Schritt in die richtige
Richtung gehen aber solche Gedanken und
so das ist ja Luxus kein Problem ich
kenne Menschen die sind in der Position
dass sie halt also das ist halt nicht in
ihrem Kosmos stattfinden kann weil sie
halt einfach andere Probleme haben ich
weiß nicht wie anders wie ich das
beschreiben soll ich will auch einfach
nichts falsches sagen aber so ich sage
mal so sehe ich das das ist noch mal zu
dem Thema und jetzt geht's wirklich mal
um Müll trennen worum es mir am was ich
am allerwichtigsten finde warum lernen
wir nicht in der Schule in in
irgendwelchen Alltagssituationen wie man
sein Müll trennt ja ich habe in der
Schule keine Ahnung grünen Punkt
gebastelt für die Mülltonne und dann
wurde uns gesagt das kommt da rein das
kommt da rein okay aber wie ist das mit
diesen Pizzakartons wenn ein Pizza
Karton ein Fettfleck hat dann gehört er
nicht mehr in den Altpapier dann gehört
dieser Pizza Karton in den Restmüll das
weiß kaum jemand ich weiß dass nur wegen
der Kooperation mit Mülltrennung wird
ich wusste davor schon Dinge und Müll
Trennung fand ich vorher schon so
interessant aber erst durch die
Kooperation habe ich wirklich ein paar
Sachen gelernt wo ich dachte krass und
zum Beispiel das Joghurtbecher dass man
den Deckel davon abnimmt den Aludeckel
in meinem Kopf war das ja Folgen wie das
doch gut dass es zusammen bleibt aber
das ist ja auch so bescheuert ein
Aludeckel wird halt anders recycelt als
der Plastikbecher und dann habe ich
diese Kooperation gemacht und dann wurde
ich erst auf diese arte Doku hingewiesen
in der ist darum geht das oder die
Recycling lüge ich glaube die Doku heißt
die Recycling Lüge und in dieser Doku
geht es darum
dass ja also das
Recycling System gar nicht so
funktioniert wie wir es wollen und es
gibt halt super viele Recycling Lügen so
und das ist dann auch total schwierig
weil was sollst du denn dann als
Konsument noch denken ja gut ich oder es
gibt ja auch noch diesen diese dieses
Phänomen oder das ist wie so eine Smith
das wenn man den Müll trennt dass der
die Müll Menschen die den Müll abholen
ist alles einfach in den gleichen
behälterwerfen und dann sagen ja viele
ja was was nützt denn noch zu trennen ja
sehr schwierig ne weil
ich weiß nicht ob es also ich glaube
nicht dass es stimmt das wäre ja so
krass
ich habe jetzt aber auch keine direkten
Erfahrung gemacht die für oder dagegen
sprechen deswegen möchte ich hier keine
Aussagen also ich möchte mich nicht zu
weit aus dem Fenster legen das wäre halt
richtig heftig aber warum fehlt uns als
Gesellschaft total das Gefühl mit den
Dingen mit den Verpackungen mit allem
womit wir uns so befassen uns bis zum
Ende zu befassen warum hört das bei
eigentlich den meisten auf nachdem Sie
ein Produkt konsumieren
sich darüber bewusst zu sein wo es
danach hingeht mit diesem also es ist ja
nicht einfach weg in Polen dort wo ich
aufgewachsen bin haben die viele viele
einfach ihren Müll
verbrannt das hat dann immer ja überall
so ein ganz bestimmten Geruch gehabt wo
ich jetzt erwachsen auch immer sage wenn
ich irgendwo lang fahre so oh das
richtig wie in Polen und dann gucken wir
irgendwann an das ist verbrannter Müll
ja dann höre ich auch z.B der pewdiepie
dieser größte Youtuber weil sie den
nicht kennt und weil kann ich auch nicht
helfen
in Japan und hat gesagt dass man den
Müll sogar auswaschen muss das heißt du
musst dein Joghurtbecher bevor du den in
die Tonne schmeißt musst du den
auswaschen lassen der Müll muss sauber
in der Tonne sein das sind auch alles
Informationen sagen bitte nicht zu
also es kann sein dass ich irgendwas
Falsches sagen so und dann ähm
wäscht du dein irgendwie aus damit der
abgeholt wird und in Japan gibt es zum
Beispiel auch keine Mülleimer so auf der
Straße also es ist anscheinend sehr
teuer Müll zu entsorgen dort und wenn
sie öffentliche Mülleimer hätten dann
würden die Leute dort ihren Müll
wegschmeißen und das wollen sie halt
vermeiden weil sehr teuer ist total
verrückt wenn man sich drüberlegt dass
hier in Berlin an jeder Ecke eine
Mülleimer ist und irgendwie also ich
habe einfach das Gefühl hier wird sich
so überhaupt nicht darum gekümmert hier
denkt keiner mehr zu Ende nach und dann
frage ich mich wer müsste denn zu
nachdenken naja müsste dann Syoss
irgendwie also müssten Firmen einfach
also es geht jetzt in jeder Feier ist
direkt lieb eure Haarfarbe aber wer
kümmert sich darum wer muss sich darum
kümmern dass da irgendwie mal richtig
was passiert weil es kann doch nicht
sein dass wir so viel Müll produzieren
mit dem nichts gemacht wird der
irgendwie nach Vietnam verschifft wird
also Müll wird ja mittlerweile wirklich
auf Containern einfach in andere Länder
gebracht und dann und dann ist das
Problem weg und vielleicht als nächstes
schicken wir unseren Müll ins All aber
wer es nicht wirklich schlau mal
wirklich sich um Recycling Gedanken zu
machen mal wirklich zu denken okay
können wir Verpackungen produzieren die
nicht vielleicht immer nur alle
plastikfrei sind sondern halt irgendwie
so aus so einem Plastik was einfach und
gut zu recyceln ist Papier und alles so
zu produzieren das ist einfach gut zu
recycling ist dass da keine Beschichtung
drauf ist die das Recycling unterbrechen
könnte kann man nicht eher in diese
Richtung gehen ich liebe jetzt schon die
Kommentare
aber ganz ehrlich es ist mir auch egal
ich möchte auch einfach sagen was ich
denke und darum geht es hier es ist ja
ich bin ja hier kein Experte oder so und
ich freue mich wenn ich in den
Kommentaren irgendwie darauf hingewiesen
werde was wie man besser machen könnte
und diese recycling-löse diese arte Doku
das ist wirklich der Super-GAU also das
ist da verstehe ich ja wenn die Leute
dann sagen ja gut und was bringt es wenn
ich jetzt noch irgendwie Müll recycle
weil das kommt ja eh nicht so richtig an
und so dann gibt's ja noch so Sachen wie
Pamela Reifs Plastik was ich ja jetzt
auch schon ich bin da auch oft drauf
reingefallen und hat das in meinen
Videos dann z.B über Adventskalender
Videos habe ich das dann auch oft so
gesagt oh toll guck mal das ist aus aus
biologisch abbaubaren Plastik aber also
es gibt noch gar nicht diese
recycling-möglichkeiten es gibt es wird
nicht recycelt dieses abbaubare Plastik
das landet einfach genauso in ich glaube
in der Verbrennungsanlage weil du daraus
noch nichts machen kannst dann denke ich
mir okay aber ist dann vielleicht ganz
normales Plastik besser weil man das
wenigstens ordentlich recyceln kann und
was tun wir hier eigentlich auf der Welt
ich sehe halt nicht dass Leute alle in
unverpackt Leben laufen dass das halt
kein Müll mehr produziert wird weniger
Müll zu produzieren ist immer gut das
auf jeden Fall ich glaube aber auch dass
die also ist es nicht irgendwo Teil der
Politik dass die sich halt kümmern muss
also klar die haben sich dann jetzt mit
Strohhalm geeinigt gut dann gibt's jetzt
nur noch papierstrohhalme
und das ist jetzt die Lösung und ich
habe eine Werbung gesehen von Rewe die
sparen und das also wenn diese Zahl
stimmt dann bin ich dann bin ich
wirklich mein Plan
73.000 Tonnen Papier ich hoffe es war
nur 73 Tonnen aber ich glaube es waren
000 Tonnen Papier werden jetzt
eingespart weil sie sich den Prospekt
sparen Rewe produziert jetzt nicht mehr
den Werbeprospekt den man im Briefkasten
kriegt dafür gibt's alles in der App
73.000 Tonnen im Jahr für für ein
Prospekt das ist verrückt und die Zahl
ist jetzt vielleicht auch falsch aber
selbst wenn es 73 Tonnen werden
wäre das auch crazy
sind aber auch so zahlen die kann ich
einfach nicht in meinem also die gehen
einfach nee ich kriege die ich kriege
die in meinem Kopf nicht hin weil ja wir
sind halt 80 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland so viele Menschen ich krieg
die Zahl gar nicht mehr auch nicht
vorstellen manchmal fühlt man sie
einfach so ein bisschen ich weiß nicht
ich meine ich man will immer das
richtige machen und bei manchen Themen
habe ich das Gefühl man ist da so mit
seinen Gedanken und mit seinen ansetzen
total lost weil man will ja das Richtige
tun aber sei doch manchmal schwer ich
möchte mir weiterhin die Haare färben
und ich appreciate jeden der wirklich da
voll angeht es gibt Leute die haben nur
ein Glas pro Jahr mit Müll weil sie
alles unverpackt haben und die sind
bestimmt auch glücklich so keine Frage
aber wie viel
Lebensqualität kann man sich bewahren
und gleichzeitig halt gut und nachhaltig
sich verhalten schreibt mir mal gerne
dazu eure Gedanken in die Kommentare
also ich will gar nicht wissen was unser
Wohnungsbau
produziert hat
und ob der richtig
abgetragen wurde recycelt wurde wir sind
jetzt kurz vorm Umzug gar nicht kurz vor
Umzug dort noch ewig ich lüge euch an
wir haben gerade erfahren dass da schon
Fliesen gelegt wurden aber nicht in
unserer Wohnung das war so gut im Anruf
gekriegt das ein Fliesenleger der
beauftragt wurde von dieser Baufirma hat
schon Fliesen gelegt und anscheinend war
das so schlecht gelegt dass die Baufirma
jetzt die nicht mehr beauftragt da frage
ich mich auch wieso was abläuft ruft man
an und sagt
nee ihr seid scheiße und jetzt wurde
eine neue beauftragt und ja das ist noch
ein bisschen hin und her jetzt aber
ansonsten läuft's gut ich bin überrascht
also es hätte eigentlich der also wir
hätten schon jetzt drin wohnen müssen
jedem den wir aber von diesem
bauchprojekt überhaupt erzählt hatten
war mal so ja ja warte mal ab wann ihr
einzieht ich bin jetzt so langsam an dem
Punkt dass wir unsere Wohnung kündigen
müssen und wir wissen aber noch nicht
unser richtiges Einzug Datum und das ist
jetzt das Problem dass wir da jetzt
meine konkrete Antwort brauchen mein
Schwiegervater hat mich gestern zusammen
gemacht
dass wir das noch nicht wissen aber ich
kann nichts dafür ich kann wirklich
nichts dafür man muss auch bei so einem
Wohnungsbau man muss auch einfach
erwachsen spielen ne also Timo und ich
gucken uns auch manchmal an und sind so
was machen wir hier gerade das ist doch
warum warum tun wir uns das an das ist
doch hier alles wir sind im Herzen halt
noch so Kinder und dann muss man sich
mit so not Grundbuch
Pipapo beschäftigen und ich kann
verstehen warum viele Leute halt diese
Schritte nicht machen weil wenn ich
jetzt zurückblicken schaue das war schon
alles echt ziemlich anstrengend und ich
weiß nicht ob das Gefühl dieser Hassel
culture will einem immer so zeigen dass
oder so vormachen das so ja also du
musst dann einfach nur drei Wohnungen
kaufen und dann lässt du sie alle von
der Bank
finanzieren und dann ist das alles ganz
einfach so nee es ist nicht einfach weil
dann sitzt du da und muss irgendwelche
Verträge durchlesen wovon du keine
Ahnung hast okay und dann musst du dir
vielleicht noch ein Berater holen der
dir diese Verträge erklärt und dann
sitzt du dann dabei dem Notar und er
liest dir irgendwas vor von dem du gar
keine Ahnung hast was der da gerade
liest und frag Dich nachdem jeden Satz
verstanden
ja ja habe ich das ist gerade unser
Leben sehr privilegiert und ich bin sehr
dankbar es ist ein fantastisches Leben
äh ich habe jetzt letztens wieder mit
Yoga angefangen und ich habe das Gefühl
manchmal habe ich so eine depressive
Wolke über mir und ich kann dann gar
nicht so richtig benennen wie es mir
warum geht und dann sitze ich da und und
ja habe keine Ahnung hat gerade welche
Laus mir über die Leber gelaufen ist und
dann war ich beim Yoga und habe richtig
wieder gemerkt so
so fühlt sich das an wenn man sich
entspannt so fühlt sich das an wenn das
Leben sich gerade wieder mal leicht
anfühlt es war so für so ein Moment hat
sich irgendwie so die Last von meinen
Schultern gelegt und ich war richtig
glücklich ich bin schnell wieder in ein
altes Muster geraten aber für den Moment
was fantastisch ich möchte auf jeden
Fall mit der euch mehr über meine
Wohnung sprechen ich merke dass dieses
Thema mich wirklich sehr interessiert
zurzeit aber auch aus einem Grund der
offensichtlich ist und ich würde gerne
auch euch mal unsere Baustelle zeigen
das ähm das ist glaube ich also ich habe
schon angefragt ob ich das machen darf
die haben aber gesagt das ist aus
datenschutzrechtlichen Gründen also weil
die Wohnung gerade noch nicht mir gehört
sondern der Bank ich bin aber auch
gerade nicht so sicher ob das
also eigentlich gehört sie uns ich aber
ja da bin ich schon wieder ne wird Notar
keine Ahnung was wieder ausgemacht haben
naja und deswegen meint sie ja wir
könnten zu Filmen aber dann erst wenn
wir quasi
den Schlüssel haben können wir erst und
die Wohnung abgenommen haben können wir
das dann erst posten weil es dann erst
wirklich unsere Wohnung ist dann hat sie
aber gesagt es wäre vielleicht okay wenn
wir vorher zeigen was wir filmen ich
glaube dir ein bisschen Angst dass wir
shady sind aber sind also wir sind super
zufrieden bis jetzt vielleicht außer mit
ein paar Kleinigkeiten aber was soll man
da machen ähm deswegen ich hoffe einfach
dass das wir jetzt da filmen können und
ich euch das mal zeigen kann weil so
eine Baustelle zu sehen ist halt auch
irgendwie so irgendwie cool und ich will
euch einfach zeigen
wie das alles so aussieht und und ja das
ist halt einfach ein komplett neues
Kapitel in unserem Leben ich bin halt
mega also es sieht sich aber man hat
irgendwie so viel Schiss dabei ganz aber
ein ganz klar weil es einfach halt so
ein großer Schritt ist andererseits ist
man halt total aufgeregt dann denkt man
über die Zukunft nach und fragt sich ja
hätten wir nicht nochmal vielleicht
Reisen gehen sollen andere Leute machen
noch so
Weltreisen und so sind wir vielleicht
solche Leute es ist auf jeden Fall alles
sehr exciting und wir sehen uns dann das
nächste Mal wieder und ich dass das
jetzt einwirken und Spiel meine Haare
aus viel anders werde ich danach nicht
aussehen deswegen entschuldige